hey what's up guys my name is the
channel welcome back to my game engine
series so last time we began upon a
series of like little mini series
towards achieving mouse picking getting
mouse picking to work
which is basically us clicking on the
screen being able to select objects
check out the video up there
where we go over setting up a new frame
buffer api that would allow us to render
through multiple
uh render targets which is very
important for the way that we're going
to be sorting out this mouse picking and
today we're going to be
continuing on that journey by actually
being able to
output um well today today's episode is
going to be kind of like an extension of
what we learned about in the last
episode which is more or less how to
define a better
frame buffer api and today we're going
to be creating a new frame buffer format
which is going to be essentially an
integer
which is going to prepare or wait
prepare the way for us to actually be
able to output our entity id
into a texture so that we can then kind
of click on
a pixel in that texture and read back
the entity id and thus select that
entity so that's kind of like the full
picture
of how this is all going to click
together so let's dive in and take a
look at where we left off
um we're going to have a nice quick
efficient episode
here today hopefully so if we open up
the
pink cube that we had you saw that um
last time essentially we were
we were testing our multiple render
targets by outputting
a solid kind of reddish color into the
second color attachment that we had and
then this is us just testing that api to
be able to
display that texture attachment instead
of the normal one which if we go back to
because we should really restore the
normal one i think
um if we just get rid of this one here
um
or put a zero there optionally because
that's it's a default parameter
that's set to zero anyway uh then we'll
be able to see hopefully an actual pink
cube all right cool so
from this now how do we convert uh
how do we convert our frame buffer into
um
basically well i don't know about
converting our frame buffer into
something else but
ultimately to phrase this better let me
show you what it's going to look like in
the shader right so at the moment we
tested this by just duplicating our
initial kind of color output
we just created another one that was
exactly the same you can see this inside
the frame buffer when we set it up you
can see we have
two frame buffer texture format rgb a8s
right
but we don't want to output a vect4
what we want to really output here isn't
it and we want it to actually remain an
int so what opengl will do um is
it will actually well you can read about
this on on the various kind of
uh like documentation pages that talk
about the various formats
but basically what rgba 8 will do is it
will convert it into a floating point
value
that's between 0.0 and 1.0 now that's a
big
big kind of no no for us because what we
want to do is we want to
basically the whole point of this is so
that we can for every pixel on our
screen
we can output the entity id that that
pixel belongs to if that makes sense so
in other words
if we render like one face of that cube
and that's nc id
5 then i wanna see a bunch of fives in
place of those pixel values right
um five is an integer value five is not
between zero point zero and one point
zero and even if it was it's
it needs to be an ant not a float um and
furthermore we definitely don't need
four
of those right we don't need like rgba a
rgba8 i was gonna say but we don't need
rgba where we have four of those floats
between zero and one
we just want one int now we could use a
an unsigned int um i'm not going to
and i might change my mind on this later
but ultimately i like the idea of
negative one
not being an entity right in still gives
us two billion
entity ids which is more entities than i
think we'll ever have on
um in our scene right uh and then also
um uh negative one is a nice little
little easy to understand easy to read
value to have
uh that will basically define no entity
so nothing is under the mouse cursor if
it's negative one
zero we can't use because and defines
zero as an actual valid id and i want to
directly use
the um entity ids from ant now of course
if i was really cool and i mean i am
pretty cool so i could do this but
what i could do is i could still use a
uint but then
from and like when i actually read back
the entity in my c plus plus api i could
really i could add a little plus one to
that
so that basically that shifts all of n's
ids by one over to the right
so in other words if zero that kind of
makes makes way for zero to be
like a uh you know an id that's not
valid
but then we have to remember that every
time we retrieve the entity id from our
api in hazel which is going to be the
ant id the entity library
id it has to be it's good it it you know
zero
is valid so we have to shift everything
every time that's a bit annoying as well
so easy solution just make it an int
assigned integer and then we can have
negative one
um again i may i may change my
mind on this later but uh for now this
is the way it's going to be so how do we
actually facilitate this
so that's going to be our kind of goal
for today i want this to be output
correctly
and uh you know let's set it to like the
value 50 or something like that right
that's ultimately what i want how do i
read that back well
um as i mentioned rgba 8 is not going to
fly here we need something
stronger um so we'll use something
called red integer and i'll explain what
this is so
basically in opengl i mean maybe it's
worth me actually implementing it first
and
and then kind of explaining it but in
opengl uh you know we have our kind of
standard like
um you know uh rgba we have
rgb we have rg and we have r
but r is called red um red is still
going to be
kind of converted to a float and clamped
between zero and one
which so it's basically the same as rgba
8
except it's just one channel that's
still not good enough
we want it to remain in an integer so we
have to
use this opengl format called red
integer and so i'm going to create a
a format inside hazel called red integer
as well
just to match that and again like we
can't call it r we could do it
we could call it ri or red i or
something but you know i'm you know me
i like to be quite verbose in my
explanation so that it's
very clear to everyone what's going on
so i think red integer
is pretty clear um so let's go back into
frame buffer texture format and we'll
we'll call this red integer i might like
again the order has
absolutely zero um influence
like into how everything's gonna work it
doesn't it doesn't matter basically what
order you define these in
i like to um i like to probably
well you can see that i'm grouping these
based by like kind of types but
with these things like you're way more
often to want to have an rgba
8 than like a red integer redditch is
pretty rare format
something like rgb would be quite common
as well but
ready to join not so much so i kind of
also like to kind of be wary of
um formats that may not be used as often
because you know you want to look at
this and be like oh i want this format
not necessarily some other ones because
we'll have we'll probably end up having
quite a lot of formats in here
that's all um okay so now we've added a
format here we need to obviously create
it
using opengl so how do we do that well
into gl frame buffer
we go um okay so ultimately what i want
to do
is i need to change this attach color
texture function a little bit
because at the moment you can see that
we take in we do take in a format which
is actually the internal format right i
called it format because it's the only
format we take in here
but then we have glrgba here as the kind
of
access format um opengl has two formats
internal format format one refers to how
the data stored one's referred to how
it's like accessed in red
um you know we need this to be gl red
integer and we need this to be like gl
i don't know 32i or something like that
so
basically we need to extend this api so
that we now have a format
but we also have an internal format
right and internal format is basically
what format
is so we need to replace that here like
that
i'm pretty sure this is yep the internal
format and then format is what goes here
now this doesn't matter too much we can
still leave it as on by we don't need
like into gel into or anything here
so for now that will remain the same and
then over here obviously we've got a
little error because we're now no longer
um uh
you know now we actually need another
parameter so rgba8
is the internal format and then gel rgba
is our regular format
okay so that's done so let's add another
case here
rgba8 and we'll also have red integer
now
that where the internal format will be
r32i
also ui for unsigned and but r32i is for
assigned integer
and then obviously this will be gl red
integer okay
that's it that's all we need to do super
simple now we're attaching a texture
that obviously has a very different
format
um and i believe that is like that's it
that is honestly it
and so now if we go back to edit a layer
obviously we'll make sure that we are
dealing with
red integer and we are um and if i run
this the purpose of running this
is not necessarily to see anything
because we won't but i just want to see
if we get any kind of
you know opengl errors or assertions or
anything like that you know for example
the frame buffer being incomplete or
um uh you know the just like a gel
like a gl error because we um are using
the wrong format or something
okay everything is good we don't see
anything here with some other kind of
you know google drive stuff leaking in
here and we'll deal with that later i'm
pronouncing not even sure what's going
on there um
but it's hijacking our console but uh
ultimately
um yeah no open shell errors so
everything is good
okay next step um is let's actually
see something work right so let's
actually
see us retrieve that value 50
back from the frame buffer because
that's what we ultimately need to do
this is like the placeholder uh for our
entity id
right 50 at the moment so what we should
see and what i want to do right now is
basically make it so that
when i put my mouse over the screen over
this viewport
i want to be able to read whatever pixel
the mouse cursor is currently under
and what i should see is
um just by outputting 50 if i'm
anywhere on this cube i should get back
the value 50.
that's my goal right now right and then
if i'm not
then i will well ideally i should get
negative 1
but if you actually think about what
this is um
this isn't is a value that we haven't
set uh we have cleared we have done a gl
clear but we've cleared it with like
0.10.10.1 and 1.0 on the alpha
so that they're all floating point
values so they're going to show up as
like
pretty large integers i think um so we
won't get our negative one just yet and
we'll talk about clearing a specific
texture attachment last time
next time last time um but
the goal is just when i'm over the cube
showed me 50. that's what i want to see
right and i should be able to obviously
move the cube wherever i want
should be able to resize the viewport
however i want and if i'm over the cube
i want to see 50.
that's the goal uh for today so let's
make that happen
so two parts to this first of all we
need to get the mouse cursor and we need
to actually get the mouse position
within that frame buffer
and not only do we need to do that but
mouse mouse cursor coordinates
the top left is pretty much always zero
zero so this up here is zero zero now as
we know with opengl and with opengl
textures
zero zero is the bottom left so we need
to do a little flip on the y-axis
of just the mouse uh cursor right so if
it's up here it really should be down
here in the texture
that's easy though we can just basically
take the viewport height and subtract
that subtract the mouse
y from that and that will invert it
that'll give us our little flip
um and then obviously though we need to
account for things like the viewport
size changing this changing
and also we probably don't even want to
uh you know
check to see what is under the mouse
cursor if we're like
not even on the right panel so only when
we're inside the bounds of the viewport
so that's what we need to do now to set
this up um and i did this before the
stream
oh like during the stream before i
started recording just to not waste
everyone's time working out the math for
this but ultimately
um to do that we need to set up a few
things with our iron gui situation
so when we actually draw stuff with the
imgui viewport right which happens i
think over here
uh where do we begin the view so we're
going to the dock space
here it is viewport right we need to
basically find out how big the viewport
size is and also account for things like
the tab bar
so the first thing that i think um we
need to do here
is uh calculate a viewport offset
um because every every um every panel
inside i'm gui which is like really a
window as well
has the potential to have a tab bar but
it kind of maintains its own internal
state about whether or not that's shown
so what we can do is we can actually get
a viewport offset by checking to see
what the current cursor position is so
the current cursor position is where i'm
gooey's now going to start drawing the
next
kind of thing that it needs to draw so
if the if the tab bar is expanded this
will be larger
that the y coordinate of this cursor
will be larger because it'll be lower
down
than if um it's not there so basically
this kind of
a little comment that this uh you know
accounts it includes the tab bar
um because that's really what we're uh
doing it
what we're using it for so once we've
got that the next thing that gets drawn
is the actual image so after we've drawn
the image we can check to see what the
cursor position is again
um but ultimately um we can basically
just ask it what the window i don't know
this is this is this
i'm just i might just copy and paste
this because i don't want to spend all
day here
um and i'll explain it but then the next
step is to
uh get the window size get the window
position
um calculat um add that viewport offset
to that minimum bound which is the
window position
and then figure out what the max bound
is by adding the window size to the
minimum bound right
so basically what we end up with is this
like little viewport bounds
uh it's kind of an array of two values
i'll add it here glm
back to viewport bounds
[Music]
and what this is is basically the
minimum and the maximum
of where the viewport is so if i
take a look at what these values are
uh bounds equals
i'll do that
um let's do this
so let's take a look at what these are
and this stuff has been in hazel there
for a while so to be honest i'm not i'm
not even 100
sure how i came up with this stuff but
so these are our min bounds and these
are our max bands i've just put them
into like an array
but basically one is like the max bound
and zero is the min bound so if we take
a look at this
to see if it's even working correctly
and then you'll see what we're dealing
with so
um six six five six and one two three
and one three nine four nine and nine is
the max bound
right so what this is is basically
telling us that like within
um and you can see that it actually
moves across like monitors and stuff
which is pretty cool um and that's
because i'm gui kind of maintains a
global position but basically what it's
saying is
where on earth in the world is
this viewport defined on our screens
right
and obviously we need to make sure that
we use this data
along with the also the absolute kind of
mouse cursor position um
so and that's exactly what we're gonna
do so the next step
is um and it doesn't matter where you do
this at the moment we're just running
tests right
so ultimately i'm gonna do this over
here um right after we update the scene
but i'm going to now get the
um the uh mouse position from i'm gui
which again will give me like a um
yet mouse position which will give me a
kind of absolute on-screen position
right um and then i'm going to from this
mx and my which i think returns a float
right this returns two yeah it's a
vector so it's two floats
well actually how how um
how is this even working okay yeah
whatever two flows
um float mx player my
so i'm going to subtract the viewport
the minimum viewport bounce from this
which is basically bringing that back to
zero right so that's now making the top
left zero zero um if i subtract both of
these
from this um there one's a glm vector
one's a
non-glm vector so that's why i'm having
to do it
separately i'm not sure if it's even
worth doing that
i guess so um and then we'll also
calculate the viewport width and height
so the viewport width will be a viewport
bounds
uh zero dot or one actually dot x
minus yeah you know what let's kind of
do this instead i don't know i might
regret this but if you've got size and
we'll just do viewport bounds
one minus um
a few more pounds zero i think the imgui
vectors
don't have operate overloading but
obviously glm does so we can just do
that instead of having to do it
individually and
if this was a an actual um
you know we could also combine this oh
that's a little bug um we could also
combine this into a
um into a into like a vector if we
really wanted to
okay so now let's go ahead and get an
actual
mouse x integer so this will be just int
mx so this is now the mouse
but it's been moved into like it's been
put into the right space now because
we've subtracted the minimum bound
so we can basically get that coordinate
and now like let's just test this out so
i'll take
um this we don't need this anymore
and i'll pop it here and i'll just
replace this with mouse
x and mouse y
okay
so now um what you should see over here
right is hopefully um
a value between
that already looks flipped for some
reason
which is a bit weird
because i don't think i flipped it
oh well oh yeah it's negative isn't it
yeah that's super weird isn't it okay
anyway the x coordinate seems right what
happened with the y-coordinate
uh
oh that was a bug yeah
i was gonna say that was weird because
yeah our y coordinate was on zero but it
was going up
um okay this is better yeah there we go
so you can see the top left is zero zero
round about zero zero if we go off it's
like negative and negative and whatever
and then obviously this is our viewport
width and height so now technically
speaking
we should be able to easily see whether
or not our mouse is within that viewport
or not
um and i can do that by just saying
basically if the mouse if mousex is
greater than zero technically greater
than or equal to zero
and mouse y is greater than or equal to
zero
and mouse x is less than viewportsize.x
um oh that's why i think i wanted to do
that just because or maybe not
because these are floats um but we can
cast them to an end
um and mouse y is less than
uh viewport size dot y
right then we are within the bounds
right so now we'll only print it if
we're there
we should be able to see that in action
right so this is zero zero obviously if
we're outside we don't care um
and then that's great because you can
see over here we're only printing one
more inside so we only care about that
and obviously if we resize
you know we should be able to um you
know that should all work
hard to see when it's not here but there
you go okay cool
so that seems to be working pretty well
now as i mentioned we need to flip the
mouse
coordinate otherwise well it doesn't
doesn't work so
to do that what we can do is tmy we can
just simply as i mentioned earlier
grab the viewport size dot y um and
subtract it from my
i'll subtract my from viewport size y so
we're just
flipping it and now you can see that
basically all that's done is
made the bottom left 0 0 which is going
to match our texture
so now finally all we need to do is ask
opengl to give us the pixels of that
texture
now reading back pixels from a frame
buffer reading back pixels from the gpu
back to the cpu
not the best thing in the world um it's
totally fine for what we're going to use
it for you know there are also pixel
buffer objects and like asynchronous
ways of dealing with this stuff
i don't want to get into the the deep
end because we don't need to at all
but ultimately what i want to do is use
a function called gel read pixels that
will enable us to read back
the pixels from that frame buffer
attachment from from that texture
ultimately
once we've rendered to it so
we'll have to add a function into our
frame buffer
so what i want to do is uh maybe we'll
put this get specification i'll do this
here virtual int
um which again we'll we might deal with
this later
uh you know the api the exact api we can
discuss at a later time but ultimately
um
we need to have an index of the like the
attachment so i'll call this attachment
index
and then like an x and y coordinate
um so we'll copy this we'll go to gl
frame buffer
we'll pop this under resize
override and then i'll implement this
so this needs to bind and unbind our
frame buffer when i assume that it was
not bound before this is a bit dodgy as
well because
maybe it's already bound and if so do we
really want to unbind it maybe maybe not
like it's a bit
you have to be careful with this stuff
is my point um because again you
wouldn't want to
re anyway you get the point um in fact i
think what i want to do
is just not bind an unbind and say that
you have to do that yourself manually
because otherwise it's going to be
really
tragic but ultimately what we want to do
is
um call gl read buffer right which will
just kind of select a buffer for reading
because it's not this frame but this
frame for this frame buffer is fine
but what i care about is a specific
color attachment so gel
color attachment zero plus attachment
index and what you could do as well is
do a little core assert
to make sure that attachment index is
less than
like the number of attachments we have
right so attachment index can be zero
and one
in this case because we have two color
attachments so that that checks out of
course
um and then we can uh basically call gel
read pixels with a whole bunch of stuff
so x and y obviously
x and y um we're only interested in
reading a single pixel
now in the future when we do like
multi-selection we might want to read a
whole region and then scan to see what
colors are there and then select those
colors right select those entities
but for now we'll just do one one uh
format
we're going to use gl red integer
as i mentioned very hard-coded very bad
um you know just uh this is you know
work in progress
um gl int is the is the type of data
we'll be writing back and obviously we
need to actually get the the data back
so
um pixel data and then pixel data i will
create up here right so we're reading
into this little memory buffer
which is an integer and then we'll just
return it
okay so we need to make sure that we
bind the frame buffer first
i think at this point it's probably
already bound
right um because we have an unbind later
i assume it's bound
so um if you want to be really sure we
can bind it again
but i think binding it might actually
clear it no maybe not
no it says the viewport doesn't clear
well whatever we'll see if it works um
and then over here what i'll do is i'll
just do frame buffer
read pixel attachment index is one
and then x and y is mouse x and mouse y
and that should be it
so that's our pixel data back
check that out
now at the moment we're doing it every
frame as long as we're in the viewport
so it will have a little bit of a
performance impact maybe like one
millisecond or so
um but we of course could change this to
make it so that it only happens when we
actually click
because that's at which point we really
want the selection
um but i don't know i don't think it's a
big deal all right so
um there's our kind of weird random
value
right make sure that my face cam's not
in the way
um there's our kind of rear a weird
random value but then when i put my
mouse over this we see 50
right which is exactly what you would
expect and then we can obviously move
this off to the side
this is fine oh there it is 50 we can
rotate it
50. anywhere where we output a color at
the moment we output the value 50.
right so those pixels obviously end up
being that
and then obviously if we're off to the
side it doesn't print anything at all it
doesn't even do the
the um read back from the frame buffer
and then it only does it here
so basically i hope you guys see where
this is going
the next step um which i would like you
guys who are following the series and
actually want to learn from it to
try and do on your own before the next
episode next week
try and somehow make it so that the
actual and
like entity ids that we have like inside
here
right this entity handle which is really
just a uint
32t right
cast that into like an ant maybe i mean
it should work anyway
it should be an implicit cast but
ultimately
somehow get that entity id into the
shader
so that you can output that per pixel
instead of the hard coded value 50 right
and then you will magically know
exactly what entity you're hovering over
and then of course you could easily make
it so that when you click
it actually selects that entity
top okay so try and do that on your own
um and then next week obviously i will
show you how i will do it but that is
all there is to it now we can see
exactly what's under the mouse cursor
um and that is more or less uh
done for this stage so if you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
don't forget to hit the like button
you can also help support the series by
going to patreon.com you'll get access
to hazeldev
which is like you know i mean i i hope
you all know what hazel dev is by now
i've been making a lot of devlogs lately
you can check them out on my channel as
well but ultimately it's a much more
advanced
it's like my version of hazel that i've
been kind of working off
uh to create this series as well so it's
got like 3d and animation and
pbr and uh physx like the it's got 3d
physics now 2d physics it's got c sharp
scripting it's got
almost everything in it that's like the
the big gun so if you're interested in
in contributing and helping to support
everything that i'm doing here on
youtube and on twitch with the game
engine series and that's definitely the
best place
to help support me and in turn you'll
get a pretty cool little
engine that um a bunch of us from the
community as well as me primarily of
course are working on so thank you guys
so much for your support
i will see you next time goodbye
[Music]
you